30 seconds to go
so
marvelous
i am here madam chair
good in that case it being 10 o'clock by
my official watch we are opening the
executive session for today
and representative goalie i believe you
have a motion
do we need attendance first ma'am chair
forgive me okay my coffee hasn't quite
worked its way through to the brain
uh i don't have the words
miss smarling i didn't i left my uh
notes home
so if you could read the uh
very well i i have it right here
um well on behalf of the chair of the
house edna
committee i find that who finds that due
to state the state of emergency declared
by the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic and
in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
202004 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically
this is an executive session on bills
referred to the committee
and a scheduled in the house calendar
for today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am
confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271 3600
or email hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote and
let's start
by taking a role called attendance when
each member states their presence please
state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
and now i pass it on to representative
scitec
yes it does okay uh it doesn't quite
reach and i don't want to use my
computer which isn't which i don't have
the link anyway i've got to look for it
um oh you're coming in loud and clear
john
thank you uh i'm gonna
take my mask off here i guess uh
representative allegro
is here i'm sorry uh representative
bailey
present in the committee room
representative fellows
phone alone home alone
representative representative
tanner um linda tanner
uh sunapee new hampshire here alone
except for my
rescue dog raven rescue joke
representative goalie here at home
and my wife will be in and out of the
room at times
here and my husband is in the home with
it's in my house with me
our house with us don't say in the home
that doesn't sound good
[Music]
good morning president uh my home office
in salem alone
represent representative president in
the committee room
the chair is president of the committee
and
uh representative pimentel
representative pimentel please say
you're here because i want to welcome
you back
it doesn't appear to be here yet not yet
okay we'll uh
we'll keep our eyes open for his he is
coming yes
okay we're expecting if you guys would
keep your eyes open for representative
judy or pimentel if i miss
their arrival please let me know
representative pearson
is i'm here
i'm in derry okay filming
okay representative roy you know the
committee
representative schmidt is here in his
home office in dover alone
a little closer is that better yes
that's wonderful that's what
i think representative pimentel has
say good morning miss uh representative
pimentel
looks like he's still connecting to the
audio oh okay
i am in my home in concord and my
husband gene taylor will be in and out
okay representative yakubovic here in
the room
here in the room and
the clerk is here in the room
and you can represent him and tell us
yes
it appears he may be having connection
problems
oh i see representative judy
representative judy is here say hello
where is he there he is yes
i'm you know i'm having trouble getting
on
well okay but we see him so i'm going to
mark him as president
all right we do have a quorum so we can
proceed
uh my plan is to do the two bills that
were noticed
for today and then do as many others as
we can
yeah doctors okay
so represent goalie you have a motion on
thank you madam chair i will move to
all right would you care to speak to
do your motion a second i'll second i'll
second
all kinds of seconds i like it uh
all right please speak to your motion
thank you madam chair um due to the time
constraints of this bill coming forward
and a new board
being assembled retirement board being
assembled with city
which has not met yet um i think we
heard there may be some
different opinions on whether this
legislation is needed and i'd like to
give that new board
board members a time to weigh in on this
um
so i'd like to retain it um so that we
can hear from them
going forward and then make a reasonable
decision on this
all right president pearson do you just
wish to speak to your second
okay is there anyone
okay doesn't look like any so the motion
is to retain house bill 211
and the clerk will call the roll
representative roy yes
clerk yes representative pearson
yes representative yakubovic
yes representative lekkis
yes representative allegro yes
yes representative show it
i'm here john yes
[Laughter]
representative fellows put down the
coffee please
representative fellows votes yes
uh the clerk heard yes uh representative
tanner
yes i vote yes representative
and representative pimentel
yes
and chair sorry yes
looks like 18 nothing 18-0
so we're short representatives
okay
face recognition i move ought to pass
question of the chair
yes are we not going to entertain how
the amendment to that bill
if i wasn't going to move the
amendment but if you wish to now is the
time
i'm perfectly i'm delighted to have you
do so
thank you i move um the amendment to
second okay
which if you would give us the amendment
number
oh i'm sorry of course i have it right
here
i believe it's zero two four seven eight
okay that was the amendment that
representative
marjorie smith presented at the hero yes
yes
i believe that you're a co-star you're a
co-sponsor of that
yes okay
would you like to speak to the amendment
yes
the amendment i believe as presented by
representative smith addresses
original bill that
involves the um
i'm sorry addresses three parts of the
bill first has to do with um
using facial recognition technology
by using driver's licenses that the
the department of motor vehicles shall
not access any of his digital
recognition
representative faces using
it for this for this purpose
and the other uses it refers to it
evidence inadmissible and it says
that it restricts the use of that
facial recognition evidence
in certain cases and
also um further defines
thank you do you wish to speak to your
second representative goalie
uh no i think she explained it well all
right
president did you uh managed to meet
representative aldshiller
yes i did and representative offshore
does not have a forthcoming amendment on
this bill
right thank you is there any
further discussion on the amendment
ah representative fellows um thank you
madam chair
um i was on the subcommittee that worked
on
the um 2019
version of this bill and with the
amendment
it is much more closely aligned to the
work that was done in the
recommendations of that subcommittee
particularly
the fact that the amendment
removes from the original bill
the provision that the surveillance
to uh if somebody if if a law
enforcement agency
did want to do does want to do the
surveillance
they can get a warrant which is
i'm not i'm not a law enforcement person
but
apparently a warrant is much easier to
obtain
than a court order so i think that um
the concerns with this bill are
addressed by the amendment
thank you representative fellows
representative shuwa
thank you madam chair i just wanted to
point out i believe i
see representative santonostasso in
attendance remotely now
yes i saw him too representative sanchez
estasso could you uh
you
he's muted yes yes
hey sorry about the delay i'm uh i'm in
keene
any uh further discussion on the
amendment
seeing none the motion is to adopt
0247 and the clerk will call the rule
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative yakovich
yes representative yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
thank you meme giusta
nestaso
i'll be back representative goalie yes
yes representative fellows
uh yes now representative tanner
yes um excuse me i think you skipped
representative schultz i did but i
uh you were right yes
terrific i like saying it myself though
just for the record
representative
yes
i believe that's uh and the chair yes
thank you zero all right for the
amendment
in that case i will move ought to pass
with amendment 0247
second
all right that's representing goalie
seconds
and uh i believe we've covered
everything
under the discussion of the amendment
representative yeah i'd like to
say this um
i'm out of step i'm opposed to all of
this
i think the police should have every a
bill ability
uh do what they need to to fight crime
because i see no
this is like ned lud at the luddites
this is the wave of the future
there'll be private concerns facebook
whatever will establish
this uh we're we're just we're
resisting uh what's inevitable
and i don't know where society is going
but i see it as inevitable
so i'm going to cast the feudal protest
no
vote but i'm happy to lose all right
thank you madam chair uh i don't
disagree with the thrust that
this is probably the wave of the future
and that the police need to have
the necessary tools to do their job of
law enforcement but this bill is not
aimed at that
it is or intended to thwart that
it is aimed at uh what i think is
going to be inevitable if we do not have
something like that in new hampshire
namely that we will have the communi
subdivisions
uh irresistibly drawn toward
um toward monitoring
uh general activity of citizens having
nothing to do with
crime or anything else they're minding
their own business
walking down the street they're going to
get photographed
and to the degree that facial
recognition is available
you'll be able to know uh with some
degree of increasing
accuracy no who is walking down the
street doing nothing illegal but maybe
whatever it is it's going to be captured
we don't want that in the state of new
hampshire and that's what this bill is
intended to prevent
thank you representative schuett thank
you madam chair
i just want to say i do agree with
representative scitec
that i think this will be one of the
tools that
law enforcement needs and particularly
we heard in the cases
of looking for missing individuals and
so forth
however we did hear testimony that the
technology is
really right where it should be at the
moment
and so i'm voting against um i'm sorry
in favor of
bill right now but i think that the
technology does need further refinement
and i'm hoping that we will reach that
point soon
[Music]
schumer
thank you i i also agree with
representative scitec except
that as technology grows
with leaps and bounds it always has to
bounce against the constitution
as so long as we have a constitution and
it's not amended to allow such things
we have to be extremely watchful that
technology does not leap ahead of and
surpass the constitution
if we think about it you know computers
are capable of
such complex algorithms today that they
could probably predict with a
degree of accuracy who's likely to
commit a crime
and if we were to embrace that
technology we might
alleviate a lot of crime but we'd also
put a lot of people in jail for things
they hadn't done yet so
i just think that as we go forward with
new technology we have to balance it
against the backstop of the constitution
i'd like to add to that that the
technology right now
is at its weakest and least accurate
when dealing with the type of people
that would that we want to find
as as lost individuals it doesn't deal
well with elderly people
it doesn't deal well with children
it doesn't deal well with with
minorities or people of color
it's at its best at identifying young
technologists because that's they're the
ones who develop the algorithms and it
works fine on identifying that
so uh i'd say that the concern that we'd
be unable to identify missing people is
first if you are trying to find a
missing person
you it and you want to use face
recognition technology
it'd be you'd have a lot of false
positives and false negatives
but even so you could use use the
positives whether they're true or not
to start your investigation you don't
have to bring it to court that the
reason
you went to such a place to look for a
person
was because of face technology you had a
a clue that they might be there and you
went and investigated it the results of
the investigation are what would go to
court not what triggered it
representative oh i wish you people
would stop you're very persuasive it's
not worth the time or the vote so let's
please move on right representative
scitec urges us to proceed to the vote
yes madam chair yes representative judy
um in any case uh
because there are some twins out there
they look alike so
we have to think about twins boys
or girls men or women so
uh because i saw something like that uh
in abc
a couple years ago one of the twins
did something wrong and then the iris
the one who didn't do nothing wrong is
still
well that's definitely of concern
yes thank you representative schmidt
thank you madam chair i think one of the
things that
needs to be emphasized is we're not just
talking to one another we are talking to
the people of new hampshire
because unlike in the past when
uh minutes of the committee meeting
we're very sketchy or non-existent
we are on the record in terms of uh
the motivations that we have and the the
understanding that we have the
technology and the courts will look at
this in the future
and and they will have a record of what
we meant
and not just a supposition and in some
cases it will be very important
for uh not only the courts but
not only the people but especially the
courts uh to be able to
deter to determine that and so what
we're saying may seem
uh self-understood but it will be
significant
for the record thank you
massive silence in that case the motion
is ought to pass with amendment
0247 made by me you seconded by
representative goalie
the clerk will call the world
clerk representative pearson
yes representative yakovich
yes representative yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative yes
representative santo nestaso going once
going twice
representative goalie yes
representative yes
representative judy we representative
schmidt
yes representative schultz yes
representative fellows yes
representative cantor yes
representative o'brien uh pimentel
yes represent the chair
yes representative santana are you back
probably all right in that case it's uh
17 to 1.
no
no there'll be no minorities all right
no minority report
and i will write the report okay
representative blackish you have a
motion uh yes
i'd like to this is on bill house bill
i'd like to move uh amendment zero two
five
all right repeat the bill number please
two one eight
itinerant vendor vendors yes
could we have the amendment number again
please 0
okay do you wish to speak to your
emotion representative license
i do um it was uh noted that
uh you know with the two bills two one
seven and two one eight one being the
um one being the
book the itinerant vendors the other one
hawker and peddlers
um which are closely related but they
had a problem where um
there were conflicting references so
that if one if both bills passed uh they
referred to
uh sections of the rsas that had been
repealed
and given that they're that close what
this amendment does is basically combine
them uh
if we adopt the amendment and then pass
218 we would be uh
eliminating the state licensing both for
itinerant vendors
and for hawkers and peddlers so just to
simplify
things that that's the point of this
amendment if the amendment passes
and 218 then i would move later to itl
217.
that's it thank you representative roy
i wish to speak yes representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh
i i understand that the
zeal for uh disposing of
uh what seemed to be you know out of
date
and no longer needed members
of the uh the statutes
however this statute is doing no harm
it's raising a little bit of money and
it provides
an impediment for casual
uh uh users
uh who may like burglars
who are thieves let's put it that way
who won't break into your house
but if your door's unlocked they'll come
in
this provides a little bit of impediment
for people who are not serious
people who are uh you know
willing to prevent sorry
present themselves uh in various
different communities
uh to try to sell goods uh
i know that they can still be uh
still be addressed by local ordinances
but this is a slightly
enhanced uh hurdle to get over that
serious and honest business people will
do
and people who are perhaps not so
serious
and will feel comfortable
perhaps going about their business
illegally
in the community and doing damage to the
citizenry
before the locality even discovers
they're they're out there
um so i'm going to be voting against
this because
the statute was adopted decades ago
and it's been serving a useful purpose
it's still there
thank you representative goalie thank
you madam chair
i too will oppose this um
i think it's more on the purview to have
these individuals registered with the
state
um when you look at what they are doing
um
and i will read from the bill
offered to sell or take orders for
merchandise from temporary or transient
sales locations within a town
or who go from town to town or place to
place within a town for such
purpose for individual towns
to keep track of these individuals are
they continually moving
um i think is a difficult thing to do
um i think by being registered with the
state the towns can uh
look to see whether they are registered
or not and
take notice from there i think it's
important when it's a transient
business that it be recorded at the
state and not with these each individual
town
thank you thank you johnson bailey
it seemed to be necessary to put in
it that is an exemption so that towns
cannot
ban candidates for office or people who
are collecting signatures for
political petitions oh i just have
that's the question political petitions
didn't seem i didn't see that
it seemed to be candidates for office i
was wondering about political petitions
i believe it doesn't say so explicitly
but
uh i don't believe that towns can
require a license from them
thank you representative allegro i i
would uh thank you
madam chair i would like to address the
three objections that i just heard
uh with the counterpoint uh i'll take
the last first
the idea that a thief for a lack of a
shorter term
is going to register with the state um
it seems to be a moot point and then the
next two items that were left
were that the bill does no harm and that
it raises money
don't seem to me to be likely grounds to
um
to have a law on the books raising money
and doing
not criteria for keeping long votes
okay representative
thank you representing the seacoast an
area that in the summertime is very busy
with
all sorts of people like this um
i am going to vote against this bill and
i hope that
people will recognize that some areas of
new hampshire are more prone to this
activity than others
thank you sam roy
thank you
i can't
[Music]
can i hear your representative roy thank
you i i have to apparently keep sharing
my
now you're good i appreciate that um so
with regard to the question about
whether this benefits the towns in
preparation for their decision
there's a local permit to do this we
heard testimony that
really nothing is done at the state
level um
to do any kind of a background check or
anything it's simply they take their
name and their money
um so with the towns have the ability
to do the same type of thing on a town
by town basis
the the police departments have the
ability to do background checks
um to make sure that these people are
legitimate
but the state really is is doing nothing
but skimming some money off of the top
of this they're not they're not doing
anything other than taking the name
and and taking the check so i just if
if it was doing what is reported
um you know putting a safety buffer then
i might be in favor but it's not
it's just a collection so i don't see
that as a legitimate reason to keep
keep the statue
[Music]
representative fellows thank you madam
chair
um i know of examples
where people have come they they drive
down your road
and they stop when they see somebody
outside or they knock on the door and
they're trying to
sell things like driveway sealants
or they say that they have leftover
um asphalt and they can put that on your
driveway
and um it that they're not
necessarily the sealants are not always
what you might expect them to be
so i think this licensing is important
because one thing it will do is if
somebody reports seeing
someone going door to door doing this
they can contact the local police and if
they don't have that license to show
then then they have um you can pick them
up and they can be charged with that
i think it's a protection for homeowners
it's particularly a protection for
seniors who might
um um
understand that this could really not be
a good deal
thank you madam chair i i basically was
going to
iterate what representative fellows just
said
as a widow who lives alone i actually
did have
someone come to my door aft shortly
after my husband passed away who
said that my husband had
given him permission to do our driveway
i contacted the local police they
verified that this gentleman did not
have a license
and actually came and assisted me in
shoeing him away from my property and i
think particularly for a female who
lives alone to be able to
verify licensure for someone who comes
to your door
uh that's that's primary importance to
me
an earlier comment was that um
there might be people who would come to
either you know go go
they're not serious they're going to go
into a locked door or yeah i mean
like the biggest issue is people come to
the door
checking to make sure nobody is home
because you know they don't want it they
want to burgle the house but they don't
want to do it with someone present
i mean that happens today i think it's
more often people claiming
um to be you know a utility worker or
delivery or something like that
and the problem is that
you know you're talking about serious
people well serious people will get the
license
um but people who aren't serious aren't
going to try and get the license
and you know it's not it's not going to
stop them from doing it i mean
there might be one case but if you see
somebody if somebody is doing something
suspicious you can still call the police
police can still look into what's going
on um
i really don't see that this having any
benefit and all you're doing
is you're making life more difficult
more expensive for the people who are
the serious vendors who are trying to do
the right thing
um you know assistant secretary of state
told us that
they had had you know in his memory
no enforcement activity no
investigations no nothing
and in effect they're doing almost
nothing and so i really see this as just
a small negative maybe a small negative
but really a number of value thank you
very much following up with
representative lekkis
dude almost nothing you mean did nothing
absolutely there is no no nothing
happened and in fact
what was really discouraging about the
test
by deputy
secretary of state was that even if the
person puts down
criminal history in their application
it's still approved
uh interesting how this is breaking out
in terms of
philosophy here that's it
thank you madam chair and while we give
the cities and towns the
ability to license um we once again i
just want to reiterate that these are
folks that go
from town to town and our transient in
our
temporary and transient sales locations
so they could be in manchester this
afternoon
or this morning hooksett by the
afternoon and
conquered by the evening there's no way
for
cities and towns to get licensing on
these folks i think it's
important if we're going to keep track
of them when they come into the state
that the state that they be registered
with the state
to track them and that's that's the
reasoning i think we have them
register with the state is because that
is a true possibility
thank you thank you representative
fellows
um thank you madam chair just as a
follow-up to some of the
recent comments if somebody is a legit
has a legitimate quality service to
offer
and they're working in a rural area like
where i live
then they would be much better served by
getting
one license with the state than having
to stop
in in a day up here they could easily
cover like five or six different
communities and they would be much
better better served with one license
from the state than to try to um
work with each town individually also in
some of the smaller towns
the um the town office
isn't even open every day of the week
thank you
works in vallejo yes i i think that
no matter where the sales offer is
coming from it's always prudent
to check out the quality of the
merchandise uh
i guess that's uh the short way to say
that is buyer beware but more
importantly
i think we're treading on some shaky
ground
when we assume that just because someone
is selling from door to door
and is driving on your street that
they're
more inclined to be crooked than uh for
instance the people who sold tons and
tons of
bad concrete to the big dig in
massachusetts i think it's a form of
prejudice
i i would suggest that we're on shaky
ground assuming
that a small business selling from door
to door is any
more likely to be dishonest than
some of the ones that advertise to us
first
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
okay the motion is on amendment
two five six h to house bill
218 and the clerk will call
representative roy yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative yes representative lekkis
yes representative electro
yes representative bailey yes
representative
not president he's still linked but he's
not
answering
yes i know i'm sorry no
no okay no no takes he's back
okay terrific he was in the same graph
that counts
representative schuett no
representative judy no representative
schmidt
absolutely not representative schultz
i'm i'm sorry this is on the amendment
right
yes sorry say that again for you yes
actually that's very interesting uh
representative selos
no representative tanner
no representative pimentel
no chair yes no
no okay yes mr
mr clerk could i please there was no
vote from from representative santos
thousand correct
correct uh thank you no vote
thank you yes representative given the
vagaries of this zoom system
uh we have someone who's clearly present
at the meeting but uh is for some reason
we don't understand
unable to vote is there a proper way to
handle that
not really that's one of the issues
madam chair yes representative
yes if i may chair has clearly stated
that
you have to have your video working in
order to vote
and i would point out that
representative santo nestaso
just has his still picture which makes
me think that he had
left his computer uh yes representative
stewart when we took the last vote
you could see his his current face in
the in the cab of his truck
all right at the moment he's not
responding so
we don't know why but he did not vote
if he were to vote it will be with video
thank you and the
motion the vote on the amendment is
representative it is 10-8 in favor of
the amendment
i might say uh i've done this in the
past
we might as well vote to improve the
amendment that took down the bill
that's here which i'm going to be doing
okay
so the amendment passes
for sonolecus i'd like to move uh hb
this amendment the amendment we just uh
passed
the correct motion is with amendment not
as amended
make sure you're using date like saving
time too
say i said okay
motion is ought to pass with amendment
by representatives
black is seconded by representative roy
i think we've had all the discussions
okay okay
in that case the clerk can call the
world representative roy
yes yes representative pearson
yes representative
yes representative lekkis yes
representative allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative giusette
no representative
no representative judy no
representative schmidt no representative
schultz
no representative fellows no
representative tanner no president
no representative no
matter of chair motion yes
and expedient to legislate
second okay that's by representative
goalie
seconded by representative schmidt and
uh
i don't think i need to speak for the
motion i think we had enough discussion
i'm just wondering representative goalie
why you think it will result in
something other than a nine-nine tie
but that's well it's going to bring it
to the store if if we
go through all the motions manager it'll
go with no recommendation
all right uh so the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
discussion no all right in that case the
clerk can call the role
okay representative roy no
the clerk let's though represent pearson
no representative yakovich no
representative lekkis no representative
allegro
no representative bailey no
representative
uh let's see representative
no representative santo nestaso are you
here
no vote representative goalie
yes representative
yes representative judy
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative tanner yes
representative grota yes
senator pimentel
now
madam chair yes uh
i'll move in expedient to legislate on
house bill
17. seeings is how in effect we just
voted on it
uh with the amendment to 218.
i'll check with you okay
that's that's
an expedient to legislate on house bill
by representative schuett seconded by
on the motion it's itl yes
i'll just say that um in fact it's going
to come to the floor
with 218 and
representative lake has stated that his
amendment was basically combining the
two
so rather than deal with two different
bills we'll deal with both on the one
sure
okay represent blackest you should speak
yes representative schmidt
we had a very kind of vehement
uh hearing on hawkers and peddlers about
10 years ago and
the committee really determined at the
time
that we should not mess with the hawkers
and peddler statute
that this is not something that we want
to let loose on our communities
without licensing and so forth and
having a central licensing operation
through the state makes sense someplace
that the towns can call
and find out whether somebody's was is
has obtained the necessary license or
not
uh we should not let our towns be at the
mercy
of potentially illegal activities
legal activities they can get the
license and they'll do their job
but you know we looked at it then the
situation hasn't changed the statute
thank you are there any any other just
all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
made by representative schuett
controlled the rules
representative roy yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative
yes representative yes representative
allegro
no no no
uh representative bailey yes
representative yes representative santo
nestaso has
returned don't see him apparently not
no vote representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes representative judy
mr representative schmidt
yes representative schultz
yes representative fellows
yes representative cantor yes
representative groto yes
calendar person like or do you wish to
write a minority report consent
okay all right what's the vote
i will make clear in the statement madam
chair that um
issues that maybe may pertain to this
bill will be
uh contained in the arguments on 218.
all right representative allegro you
have a motion on house bill 606
2. the motion is
ought to pass and um
house bill 606 ought to pass by
representative
yes
you wish to speak to your motion yes
please thank you
um i support this bill because it uh
i believe it uh remedies some current
failings
in the uh in the present structure of
the law
uh i won't go through all of them thank
goodness
you also say uh but first and foremost
is that the government was never
intended to intervene in neighborly
activities
like cutting hair filing nails and
coloring each other's hair
second is that i think that the
testimony and opposition was lacking
uh so this was about um
aesthetics and hairdressing without
remuneration just to remind everyone
uh
there was a lot of talk uh in testimony
against this bill about diseases
and myths and burning people's hair by
putting chemicals in it and such
but i never really heard any anything
concrete
they were just all threats that we all
appear to face
so i asked a question about consent
what if a consenting adult asks another
consenting adult
if you'll color my hair and i didn't
receive a proper answer
so i just made a quick list of a few
things that consenting adults can do in
this state
we can drive each other in cars even
though there are
hundreds of automobile debts every year
so it's a dangerous activity
and there are actually statistics
available on it
we can buy or offer each other
cigarettes even though there are over a
thousand cases of
diagnosed lung cancer in this state
every year and hundreds of deaths
so there are statistics to say that
giving someone a cigarette
is is dangerous we can have all forms of
unprotected sex during which uh
stds may be passed some of them
disfiguring and summoning
some of them fatal so it brings me back
to the question
if my wheelchair-bound grandmother
asked my wife to put a little
commercially available miss clairol
hair coloring in her hair why should
this be a class a misdemeanor i think
we've
experienced some great government
overreach
in this and so that's why i support the
bill to peel back some of
some of this government interference
thank you dr roy do you wish to comment
thank you i would just add that
the ability to to help people
particularly disadvantaged people who
can't necessarily afford to go to a
professional establishment
some people volunteer their time i
i don't think that it's a good idea to
keep them from being able to do that
so as long as people are consenting to
it
and are people willing to do it for free
i
think that the government really
i got a uh a call from a constituent who
said
that she was trying to volunteer to get
haircuts
at a homeless shelter and was told that
in fact even a my hairdresser was unable
to give free haircuts
because because the board
felt that that was inappropriate
madam chair um i'll just point out that
we did have
uh professionals in these fields testify
at the hearing
that many of them do volunteer at
such venues either for free or
very reduced rates i'm curious if
your hairdresser was denied going into a
nursing home
just because of the covet threat it was
not a nursing home
she was offering to give free haircuts
to children
in a local park properly socially
distance and wearing a mask
no i don't know if perhaps the whoever
ran the park
felt that it was inappropriate but i
know that
nursing homes and shelters and so forth
do accept
licensed volunteers thank you
thank you madam chair just making sure
my mic is on um this is a
solution in search of a problem parents
cutting their daughter's son's hair
are not prosecuted in the state that's
not what county attorneys
local law enforcement is involved in
this is to prevent people who
know should not be doing this
because they don't have any any
background
haircut will cure itself but fooling
around with chemicals
is a is a way to be a fool and
and and and have a friend for a fool as
well
um so that
this this is another situation where
this zeal to get rid of statutes that
are not doing any harm but do some good
um you know is biting itself in the butt
so i'm not going to support this
this time or any time it comes up
because it doesn't do any good
just meddling in an arrangement that
works fine right now
representative fellows thank you madam
chair
um i want to make the point that
i think that this opens the door for
people to operate
illegal establishments they can
they can set up a room to do haircuts
and to do
all sorts of um treatments on
people and not put up a sign
and through word of mouth or even over
the internet
people can become of where aware of this
and go to this location
and should they get reported and someone
comes by to check on them all they need
to say is like oh i was just doing it
for friends and doing it for free
so that's one point and i i did
hope i can um some of you may remember
that we had testimony
from a licensed cosmetologist and he
told
us that to provide services for a
charity
which would be for no remuneration that
he can get that you can get well people
who are licensed
can get a certificate to do this
from the licensing board and that
there's no
charge for that certificate thank you
president bailey did you have something
no no
okay
fine i'm going to
respond to representative schmidt by
saying
that i am very strongly against
selective enforcement of our laws
if it's against the law then it should
be prosecuted
as when it occurs and not when
they think oh well it's just somebody
cutting their kid's hair
that's that is a recipe for corruption
and corruption basically
and i am strongly opposed to it and i
believe
that since representative santa masaso
is not with us
i'm going to drop this this
this bill we will come back to it
because i don't see any neat
any need to go off on these
yes um got a message that he had an
emergency
oh i'm sorry i hope it is no details
no details okay well i'm glad to know
that he is
letting us know what he's doing so we
will move on to some
some other bill that we have you're
recessing this
this one yes we'll pick it up at a later
date
madam chair i really don't understand
how we cannot vote on this bill yet vote
on other bills
that doesn't that doesn't can you please
explain that
we can vote on other bills
where there's an expectation that we
thank you for example representative
lekkis
madam chair can i just ask that maybe
representative allegro withdraw his
motion so you don't have a
pending motion you know
sort of hanging out there not voted
thank you pam because i was just going
to ask the same question there's a
motion on the floor
thank you thank you thank you very much
for reminding me that we need to do that
first
and representative roy needs to withdraw
his second i believe
yes we got a message from representative
santa mustafa that he had an emergency
okay sergeant delay just getting
organized here
i'd like to propose amendment zero
three zero six h to house bill 456.
zero three eight six zero three zero six
h all right okay
all second i'm sorry i missed which bill
we're talking about i apologize
v6 hb 456. thank you
speak to your emotion okay uh just as a
reminder this is the bill
uh relative to the disclosure of
information from
there was um agreement as i recall
from the assistant secretary of state
on this this amendment takes care of two
issues
one is it just says the department of
corrections
it adds the department of corrections
shall have access and the key is to a
limited set of vital records
information importance with the
provisions of rsa
21 h8 et cetera um
and that was and both the uh assistant
secretary of state
and the person who was there from the
department of corrections
agreed with that change and actually
thought it was a good idea
they probably would have only gotten
certain records anyway but it's better
to make that clear
ms smarling actually caught two errors
in the existing law
there were two places if you look at the
amendment on line
17 and 27 there are two places where
it said you know limited data set
and uh in the somehow it managed to get
through enrolled bill and everything
else
it was limited date set which makes no
sense
so it just changes those two words from
so thank you
[Music]
i just want to thank representative
lucas for the explanation on the change
to this second amendment because i was
going to ask the question
why there was a second amendment versus
amendment
zero two eight two so thank you for the
clarification
welcome it was confusing there were
actually i think two other amendments
proposed
and this one incorporates all the little
details right incorporates them plus the
uh
all right seeing no uh
no discussion the motion is to adopt an
amendment
0 3 0 6
h to house bill 456 and the clerk will
hold on
representative roy yes clerk yes
representative pearson yes
representative jacob yes
representative representative allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative
yes representative goalie
yes representative show it yes
representative judy representative
schmidt
yes representative schultz yes
representative fellows yes
representative cleaner
yes representative grota
yes representative pimentel yes
yes i'd like to move uh on to pass with
second second okay
all right this time all right
do you wish to speak to your malcolm i
do um
basically what this does is it lets the
secretary of state's office to give
a limited set of information that the
department of corrections
requires for certain functions um
a person for department corrections said
that if they didn't get this
they would have to pay to go to outside
commercial data sources and things of
that sense uh nature
and i mean that makes no sense in my
view so
we're giving them access to a limited
set of data they need to uh
to handle um you know particular things
that are necessary
i forget some of the examples but uh
that's just basic information how they
need to uh
yes yes bailey you had a question no i i
i assumed
it had to do with restitution that was
the one of the reasons they need this
information yes
there are comments questions discussion
and i'm sure who was the second on this
motion
representative roy thank you
any any uh comments no i've embraced
everything that uh
representative all right that's very
efficient of us
just to fill in the gap i think a couple
of the other examples were having to do
with marriage
status the contact in the air that sort
okay the motion is ought to pass with
amendment
zero three zero six h on house bill 456
and the clerk will call the roll
representative roy yes
yes representative yakov
yes representative lekkis yes
representative allegro
yes represent bailey yes representative
ducette
yes representative goalie
yes representative it yes
representative judy hey
representative schmidt representation
uh representative estasa are you here
no response representative schultz yes
representative selos yes representative
cantor
yes representative broda yes
yes
yes i have a motion on house bill 230
um can we just establish is 456
going on consent oh sorry if there's any
if you are with us uh please please say
so
uh we hope your emergency can't respond
he can't respond yet madam chair he
hasn't completely come in he's on his
camera's showing
all right um
so on house bill 230 what is your motion
okay who is the second
okay do you wish to speak to your
mission representative roda
i will thank you very much um i think
house bill 230
is has good intentions to address the
issues that we have surrounded some of
the issues that we have surrounding
daycare new hampshire
however there are a lot of moving parts
this bill and
um i think that there we need some time
to put it together
in light of the additional
responsibilities that we have
with all the bills that we'll be hearing
on the house so you can as you can see
from yesterday things
may take longer in some cases than we
think and we may be having a lot of
health sessions which i think takes away
from the time that we have
to really focus on this bill and i would
like to the committee to
um support that motion so that we can
put something together that we can all
be
uh we can all support okay
um she said it very well i'll just add
that
you know there are some good amendments
i think
good amendments that we can work from um
that would be helpful but i don't think
we're at a point of agreement yet
i'd like to add that the department is
revising its rules
in which many of the requirements for
these
these people are are
instituted rather than in statute and i
would very much like to see what the
revised rules are
and madam chair i'd like to add to that
i agree with you that
um i know that one of the administration
folks that spoke on the bill
did say that a year ago maybe covet got
in the way
but um i personally had concerns i don't
think i'm the only one
that um i'm not yet sure
or not yet confident that the
administration official
that is in charge of that
has the follow through so i hope you're
right
i want you to be right madam chair
thank you madam chair and i too want to
reiterate um
that i hope someone from the department
is here and the participants listening
to this because
we did give them a year to put
uh cpr and first aid into rules we know
departments have met over the time and
rules have been done for certain
departments
um they have not yet done it for us and
this is the last time we're going to
hold out on this and give them the
opportunity
we'll put it in statute if they don't
want to move along so i just want to
make it clear with these folks that
we're watching and we want to make sure
this is taken care of
hey anyone else representative fellows
thank you madam chair i i just want to
add that i
read the current rules related to
professional development
and i think that um the improvement
there can be improvements in that area
that would that everybody can get on
excellent anyone else
representative does this have to do with
the inspection
of these places there's something
to do with inspection results yes
i just this is more philosophy than
anything else so bear with me for a
minute and a half here
my interactions with state government
whether i'm a rep or not have always
been good
i've got wonderful service people try
they really do i am concerned for
i've echoing in my mind is the testimony
of inspectors throwing their weight
around
that the teaspoon was pointed north
instead of pointed south
i don't know whom to believe whether
the offending reportedly offending
daycare center was just trumping
something up
uh i just don't know who to believe
but i'm always on guard for people
throwing their weight
around i don't know if there's any way
to prevent that
in rule or statute but that's the most
that's a very discouraging prospect for
me
i don't know how to put my finger on it
all right in that case the motion is to
retain house bill 230
representative roy yes representative
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson
yes representative jacob
yes representative yes representative
allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative giusette yes
representative uh santo destasso is
apparently not back yet
we're not hearing the questions put
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes representative judy we miss you
okay ufc uh representative schmidt
yes representative schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative
excuse me representative kander
yes
representative yes president
yes and chair
yes zero
let's take a 10 minute break recess
[Music]
i'll mute the room adam chair just
remember to unmute when you're ready to
um
okay
during the recess we had a caucus and
we've agreed that the most appropriate
thing to do
would be to end today's session on the
high note of having voted out five bills
and uh since representative santander
sasa will not be joining us for the rest
so on that case we will see you all on
monday
on the public hearings for four bills we
will have a full committee work session
on on the emergency order bills
after the hearings and i hope we will be
able to come to some
reasonable conclusions on those bills
madam chair yes representative goalie
just a
quick question on house bill 218 is that
going to go without recommendation i'm
just wondering whether
we're writing a split report not yet
there's a uh we're not up against a
deadline
so i'm not gonna i'm not going to send
it out
today
at the moment we have not we have had
two tie votes so it's
uh
if those two votes failed what other
we can reconsider we can reconsider the
motion
one of the motions because
you know on on 274 i didn't mind sending
it out with no recommendation because we
really were
uh unable to agree on anything
i think that on tues on uh 218 we
we will agree even if we end up with a
very partisan divide and i would rather
have a recommendation
than to put out a whole bunch of bills
with no recommendation and make us look
like they're
we're idiots that's
my personal preference so i'm i will not
move out on
yes representative
i always forgot to tell representative
terry roy
welcome back to edna
excellent thank you representative
pimentel yes thank you for joining us it
was
it was a pleasure thank you that was why
my hand was written i i just wanted to
uh say i was very glad to be able to sub
on my old committee and see all of you
again
and hopefully i'll get to do it again
because i
i really enjoyed being on edna last
session so yes well excellent thanks to
everyone
thought and that's i really liked
the in-person session they got to talk
to people
in a way that you can't talk to here and
it just
felt better uh and i hope we
i just like the personal bonds that
you've made
uh you just i agree with you
uh tech i i'm
looking forward to getting back into
the lob again uh i've already had my
first shot
and i will probably start attending
again
uh in march so i'm actually looking
forward to
um actually being in the lob
why not next saturday so
excellent meeting again on
monday at 10 o'clock with hearings in
the work session
and uh we have also have a a further
executive session
on uh weather modification and whatever
else we can get to
on thursday next week and then on monday
the 8th we have our last
scheduled meeting before we have to vote
okay thank you all for coming and i'll
see you monday thank you have a good
weekend
happy nice weekend god bless you